all right hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and I'm just checking in
on you as you can see I dressed up a
little bit you know I'm on a video here
on the internet whatever you call it on
the Super 8 you know I have a guest and
I dressed up because he's always
dressing up this guy's one of the most
legendary stand-up comedians of all time
certainly of my generation a guy I've
looked up to forever and when I first
started doing the road I used to be like
I want to be like this guy I want to
travel like that uh the one and only
Doug Stanhope thanks for having me sir
how are you sorry about that uh that was
a very awkward what just happened
evidently your people and my people have
been talking about show ideas and uh all
of a sudden a pitch meeting sprung up
out there yeah they said can you show up
a half hour early and I was sitting
there going oh oh they told me I thought
you were a half hour early
that's hilarious yeah I thought you were
dying or something what the [__] I
thought you were dying you're gonna be
like listen bill this is my last time to
La is that what happened why are they
such [__] [__] yeah well you said
yeah I mentioned that to to the guy the
comedy death camp and I go yeah I
remember that was an idea but I didn't
even know like you produce [__] [__] I
haven't seen you in [__] years and
all of a sudden they spring a pitch
meeting all right I thought it was a
nice way to reconnect
for me to sit well what was funny is we
were just sitting there shooting this
[__] for like 20 minutes and then I got
in my head going like has it been so
long that I saw that I've seen you that
you felt like you needed to reconnect
with me it's like I've known this guy
for like 25 years
um which is what I was alluding to when
we um
when I did the uh the intro from way
back 90 seconds ago I remember when I
when I was uh
when I was starting out not starting out
I was about seven eight years and like I
wanted to start doing the road and I
wanted and I wanted to do the road I
want to go out there I want to do all
the hell gigs I wanted to you know live
all of those stories and I remember you
and Hedberg were just out there doing it
and that's like what I wanted to do and
they they had this big um
showcase down the Laugh Factory
and it was my favorite showcase I ever
did at the Laugh Factory in the 90s it
was no networks nothing TV or movie
related it was just club Owners but for
whatever reason we're in town
and I was so [__] excited to go up
there and kill so I could go to these
places and I remember saying to this
other comic who later went on to star in
a trilogy
of movies I remember saying like yeah
you know I heard the guy the guys from
Stanford and son in Kansas City out here
and he lit and uh he just looked at me
goes
I don't want to go to Kansas City and I
got all in my head like oh [__] should I
not want to go to Kansas City but I I
wanted to go to all of those places and
then I quickly found out I was like wait
a minute the sports stadiums are here I
want to go look at them what if I got to
go to a game like it was uh for me uh
doing the road for the first like I
don't know eight years was this giant
field trip yeah of a loner sports fan
nerd and everywhere I went to do stand
up you you and Mitch Hedberg you guys
were like the legends
um the [__] stories
of all this [__] specifically you and
what you did in the comedy condos and
all of that yeah I remember the last
time I did your podcast which has been a
long and one of your podcasts how many
do you have now
I I just have this one and then I do a
one with Paul verzi we just talked about
sports games
Eagles over the uh commanders where the
Eagles were unbeaten and you go no
Washington's gonna win this Philly's
going to screw it up so badly they're
gonna lose to some [__] schlub
divisional team yeah I was bad this show
I was I was you know busy editing
something so I I didn't watch enough of
it this year so Versi is the one versy
beat the book two years in a row nice
um
uh yeah but I did your uh you had one
with Bert because I did that so Bert was
the one that we did during the
quarantine it was like during a
quarantine we're just sitting around and
missed friends and all of that type of
stuff so we were like why don't we just
I can't that's another one like how did
that even come together then it came
together and then the quarantine ends
then you get busy again it's just like
it just got to the point I said I don't
have time
to [__] do all of this yeah I wonder
how many podcasts that people just
invented during quarantine are gone now
yeah there was a lot I like Bird's still
[__] cooking didn't he have a cooking
show or something yeah something's
burning I think the rumor is is he still
he's got more episodes I think he's got
more episodes coming up uh where he will
be burning more stuff
um
I actually uh actually made my wife a
grilled cheese sandwich when she came my
wife was all my wife was on the road
right and she came back uh she was
actually just doing like a girls trip
like because I did a golf trip with the
guys I don't really even golf it's
[__] hilarious dude I'm the funniest
golfer ever where like I take holes off
I heard that podcast because uh yeah
you're with your guy there what's his
name Mussolini no Berlin
[Music]
Mike Mussolini I kind of like that dude
that's a [__] great one uh yeah
Hennigan said that yeah your guy talked
to Hennigan and said yeah we were
playing golf and then on the way back he
said you drive because I got a podcast
and he said you just podcast right in
your iPhone and then send it yeah it's
that easy I like I wish I knew this
simplest thing no I think a big mistake
that certain people make is they try to
make it too big and then it just becomes
like this giant pain in the ass like I
never wanted guests I do it now now it's
like fun because we actually have a you
know this setup I don't have to deal
with anything but like
I just did it I did it first just as a
way to like you know promote my dates
but
um I didn't want to deal with guests
because I know like uh dude 20 minutes
out can you do this I can't can we
reschedule it's just like and my whole
thing is like I didn't get in this
business to have a [__] job yeah I
don't want to start like working on like
um it might be the beginning of Taxi
when they would have the taxi schedule
trying to figure out when to send Jim
out and whatever it's like I don't want
to [__] deal with that dude I just
wanna I just wanna like
you know like uh like when I went
golfing with bertolina was the last time
I was here I was just like you know I
was going golfing with the buddy of mine
I go yeah we're going golfing on uh
Monday I'm like you want to play hooky
he's like yeah [__] it let's do it it's
just to be able to live a life like that
forget about whether you make money or
not if you can actually pay your bills
and but you're living a life where you
could just be yeah okay a bunch of [__]
yeah I know but I mean but even before I
was doing a bunch of [__] I could go see
a Kansas City Royals game during the
[__] day where if they scored 12 runs
uh uh what was the one that wasn't
Dunkin Donuts the crack one the other
the other donut [__] thing uh Krispy
Kreme you won a dozen Krispy Kremes you
want a dozen donuts if the Royals who
absolutely [__] sucked when I went
they were gonna win like 30 games that
year if they somehow scored 12 runs
against some [__] team
Krispy Kreme would give everybody a free
dozen donuts and dude they was it was
like 11 to 8 and the [__] place was
going nuts like George Brett was still
there and this guy got up and hit like a
bloop single or something and they
scored and it was like he I was unbelie
you almost saw like how you run for
president it's like this is not about
the issues it's what give me just give
me some free [__] that's gonna be gone
in a half hour hey I like this guy gave
me free donuts I mean they were going
[__] nuts no one was going like what
is baseball at this point we're [__]
Boston and New York just use our whole
franchise as like a [__] farm team
they the second year they were mad about
that you gave them free [__] donuts
over always forgiven it was amazing so
anyway my wife was coming
coming but I just like doing that like
the news well with the jacket yeah it
feels good it feels right you feel like
you know things yeah my wife is coming
off the road and I was [__] dead ass
tired and her flight got canceled and I
hate coming back from the road to a
quiet house I just [__] hate that
[__] so I sucked that up and I was just
like you want something to eat you know
you want a bath or something ready you
know just those types of things because
I'm an [__] so I gotta make sure I I
build up once yeah some frequent flyer
miles that I can use when I'm being a
dick so [__] crush this grilled
cheese sandwich man
cut into it was crunchy
it's the whole the whole [__] deal we
are so off the rails right now we're
actually here to promote oh yeah no
that's what it is because you're
steering this towards me and then I'll
start talking I know yeah I know what
you're doing you're one of the great
comics of all [__] time and you're
going to one of the great countries and
continents in the lower hemisphere yeah
and it's summer there I'm such a [__] I
live in Arizona and you know it can I
say where you're going first before you
literally you're like I've never met a
guy so anti-promoting himself yeah
you're uncomfortable yeah it's like a
Patrice level uh Doug Stanhope who you
must go see is going to be touring
Australia he's going down under
everybody uh February 18th to March 3rd
got some days off in the middle this man
knows how to tour brisbane's
February 18th February 20th in Perth you
got to go visit Bond Scott's grave if
you never did that little creatures seen
his uh statue there on the beach right
yeah yeah it's cool Sydney Australia not
one but two nights at the North's
Auditorium February 24th 25th 27th and
is it Canberra I never Canberra Canberra
where is that it's the uh it's South
Central I believe I mean for an American
comedian that's a pretty isn't that a
secure one
yeah it's capital capital of what
Australia it's not Sydney or Melbourne
no
oh that's like how like albany's the
capital of New York yeah all right so
they some great [__] was happening but
not for a while right well like Ottawa
is the capital of Canada it's like is it
I don't even play Glory Days
um Adelaide March 1st March 3rd you'll
be in uh Melbourne um that's a fun city
yeah Melbourne's a fun city I went last
time I think I went there I just
happened to go there in the in the U.S
open kind of like Portland Seattle where
or Austin maybe where it was really cool
I like Seattle I think it might it's
been a while since I've been there but
it's like it's uh not as hip as it
pretends it is like Austin you know they
get a little [__] snooty I think
that's the place that they'd get in
trouble for saying [__] if there is a
place over there but I know isn't it
wild I remember being in Melbourne at
one point and saying saying how you're
all racist and they [__] cheered
like what wait isn't it kind of a weird
thing how like when we were young older
people used to get offended you if you
pissed off older people you were in
trouble and the older people were the
establishment and now that we're old
it's like younger people are the
establishment and they're the ones that
can end your career like this has been a
weird like when do we get to be the
[__] going like hey I don't like
what you just said there that offends me
and my bald Ginger [__] Universe
um I actually think that most of that is
is complete horseshit anyways I think
it's a very small amount of people
I always take off between Thanksgiving
and Super Bowl and as I say and how you
should just be through January 1st now
you go all the way to the Super Bowl
well I I always have like I I I've done
the last couple years I've done uh New
Year's Eve in Vegas but otherwise
Thanksgiving through Super Bowl I'm
watching playoffs and [__] and uh
but now the my [__] house burned down
didn't burn down but no you're telling
me that so so I yeah I've been living
out of hotels for the entire year
you had a fire like electrical fire
goddamn space heaters right yeah yeah so
it was all burned from this ceiling up
all these canceled Comedians and you can
still sell a space heater you know
but I had solar put in so I'm like [__]
I'm gonna get a bunch of space heaters
I'm not going to use gas if I get free
electric because I get solar well it
burned the [__] roof down so now they
have to take off the solar paneling and
then take off the roof and rebuild the
[__] so at least they're gonna post
Doug Stanhope rants against solar power
hashtag [__] you Jimmy Carter point is
that so I I I I I was gonna cancel
Australia just because the insurance has
been just a [__] nightmare to deal
with they're the worst yeah what if I
have to sign [__] when I'm in Australia
and I go [__] it it's summer there I
don't those guys are [__] criminals
they're literally [__] criminals and
none of those [__] all of these
platforms that going off right there
trying to like [__] destroy people in
the individual's life they don't do [__]
to them you can turn the food supply
into poison you can [__] get people
addicted to heroin you can do whatever
the [__] you want as long as you buy
commercial time on those [__] [__]
channels CNN and Fox News and they don't
say a [__] but if you're an
individual
yeah I get it if you're driving a little
van fixing people's sink and your dick
fell out of your slacks one day forget
it you're going down I can't go a State
Farm quite yet because like first of all
they have to deal first of all they
gotta find someone to work I live in a
small town where no one wants to [__]
work it's like everyone's on disability
or you know Social Security or something
how did you end up it's a cool town I
found when I was I had to leave La I was
fed up and I found this town that I'd
gone back to I was just killing time
between gigs in Phoenix and El Paso I
had three days off so I just driving
around and it's just such a beautiful
town and it's 5 000 people and I love
small town I love no traffic it's
amazing it's usually small town means
[__] hillbilly yeah redneck but this
is kind of a half artsy half he's still
he's perfect people that have a sidearm
in the [__] convenience store and
people that are like spaceships yeah
exactly that's the balance small
beautiful balance yeah
some chick with uh white chick with
dreadlocks with a rainbow color in it
that's all right I can yeah those towns
are um I'm not gonna say the name
because it's I don't want a bunch of
people to move there on this guy but I
know a comedian that moved to a town
like that in a midwest state and you
went out there and you're like oh this
is a this is a nice little it has that
the older guy well it has he a mayor at
that time
no are you talking Clint Eastwood no I
was thinking Drew Hastings
he moved to some small Ohio town I think
oh that's amazing mayor had a scandal
funny guy
had a scandal okay I'd forget some the
uh some [__] threw herself at him
no I'm kidding
um some Financial tale as old as Ohio
itself comedian Moves In a Small Town
becomes the mayor and has it just must
have been a second I just played Dayton
and uh I guess it's a second little town
it was Yellow Springs Ohio which is like
30 minutes out of like I want to go to
Chappelle's town and uh just get a real
estate person to show me around just for
the rumors to spread while you're there
there's a there's a farm there
that has you know to sustain the farm
not only are they farming they also have
like a restaurant and a dairy Place one
of the greatest milkshakes I've ever
gotten in my [__] life if you're
literally looking at the cows as you can
tip your glass to them I did his covet
shows I have thought about that
milkshake for [__] oh [__] I mean it
was like two years ago when the hell was
that 2020 or 2021 I can't remember if if
he had those shows I think it was the
next year I don't [__] remember I
just remember that milkshake though I'm
not a food guy like that but there was a
place we just hit in Nashville Tennessee
that had the best breakfast taco I've
ever had and for the rest of the tour
every morning at breakfast we're going
[__] yeah chasing it yeah nothing still
sitting on you're gonna tell us the
worst what's the name of the place I
don't remember
the name of your milkshake place no but
it's the only giant barn with rides it
has like a [__] water slide next to
some cows I mean all right well if
you're in the Nashville zany's condo
look for breakfast breakfast tacos near
me and it's the closest one okay yeah
that's how I found it yeah because who
the [__] has tacos in Nashville I
but they're not as rare as you think but
it's not like Maine
Maine actually had a decent burrito when
I went there one time in Portland all
right how [__] old are we I'll tell
you it has a good cup of coffee Grand
Rapids Michigan they got a lunch counter
and a special if you walk in there and
you have Funny Bone passes in the sport
coat I like what we're both dressing
like 80s Comics I I did a thing the
other night and I just decided I was
going to dress like the comedians that
uh inspired me all of those 80s comics
for better for worse a lot of them
because they were funny and then towards
the end they gave me like well I could
[__] do that Jesus Christ you know
when this person was on
yeah what's more inspiring is watching
really great comedy that you want to get
that good or just watching real [__]
comedy where you go I don't have to try
that when you start I think before you
when you're trying to get the courage to
start I I felt it was a combination of
both watching these amazing Comics being
like oh man that must uh somebody you
know just something about draws you to
it you some crazy reason think that you
can do it and then when you watch bad
comedy you like I you know because then
you see the great comic you're like how
the [__] do you how is he so relaxed how
do you do that [__] then when you see
the bad one you're like oh I can I mean
I could do that and he got on [__] TV
[__] maybe I could maybe I could never
watch Comedy I don't know how much you
do but I did because I don't want my
[__] brain's leaky enough and spongy
from alcoholism so I don't want to you
know get that thing in my head uh yeah
and then say it yes you want it floating
around thinking it's one of your
references yeah that's why I kind of
stopped doing them my thing is for some
reason if I watch some somebody at a
club it doesn't stick it doesn't stick
in there but if I watch it on TV if I
sit down and watch a special I think it
gets lost in my brain with oh I saw this
on TV and this is an okay reference like
I'm making fun of Law and Order or
something like that yeah like I can
watch like a Maria Bamford where I know
she's not gonna say anything yeah yeah
she's so original but during quarantine
I started watching like some of the new
guys that I hear about and uh
but a lot of the like my peers I'm like
I hope this is mediocre
I just kind of Hope
yeah yeah I don't watch uh I don't watch
much of it I watch old movies for old
movies to me like in like the 70s and
stuff I was telling you earlier I'm kind
of on this Burt Reynolds kick and uh
tonight I'm watching some movie I'm kind
of a movie night that I watch with some
buddies of mine and uh I think we're
gonna watch this Billy the Kid movie
that has like James Coburn in it or
something like that who like James I
mean James Coburn it's a [__] so I I
kind of do that and then what happens is
is the world keeps moving on I think
it's part of being old part of being old
is you should not know what's going on
right I I hope so while while you
lecture people younger than you
everybody has a [__] opinion
Twitter's ruined because it's just
everyone's got an opinion about every
[__] thing and so no it's it's
beautiful to not know what's going on
yes no it is it is it's nice radical
apathy that's what I did but I won't say
though there are for as much as this
Becca there's a lot of funny people on
Twitter and on Instagram there's some
[__] hilarious [__]
on Instagram and I feel like I feel like
Twitter's harder because you have to
deal with your words
um where Instagram is you know but
there's an art to that too but like uh
of course I can't think of anything
there's been [__] that like people write
to me
on on my Twitter when I look at it and I
[__] burst out laughing like if it's
just that right level of mean and funny
it just [__] now everybody's gonna
fight about me you know what uh the old
movie I watched that I really remembered
almost none of was a [__] network is
yeah so good and so like relevant to
today it was so good I've seen a movie
twice and I kind of forget it too other
than when he's I'm mad as hell yeah I
can take it anymore I remember that and
then I combine it with that guy who shot
himself in the mouth on yeah I'm like
Bud waiter yeah did that happen on
YouTube or is that a network it all just
starts like blending together I don't
know but I will tell you uh you know I
really enjoy
uh whatever the whatever part of my life
this is I've been enjoying the hell out
of it well you do [__] like you're
[__]
you fly helicopters for [__] sake I
know it's funny don't do anything like I
took it when last time we were in
Australia Hannigan knows a guy down
there that has a helicopter and has this
gorgeous restaurant but it's still but
and he flew us from whatever Adelaide I
think to the coast where his restaurant
was at like a hugely afraid of heights
and I'm very claustrophobic so it's like
two of my biggest fears perfect in one
and so I you know had a few belts
beforehand and uh it was boring as [__]
I was prepared to be terrified like I'll
get material that's good nothing else
and I'm like no that's a good thing that
means that guy he flew you nice and safe
yeah but I was kind of hoping he'd go
[__] low and slow over the rice
paddies with a [__] gun if you asked
him to he probably would have I don't
think he'd go slow I think he you got to
keep your air speed so you can enter a
flip but like yeah something like that
um yeah I've flown with guys like that
I've flown with guys there's two types
of guys guys I just want to fly around
and the guys want to do [__] and guys
don't want to do [__] it's just like you
realize you're doing [__] and I'm here
right don't I get a say in that like
watch this
it's one of those things I flew out of
this guy I wanted [__] Robert Duvall
from Apocalypse Now All right well I
know a guy that has one of those
helicopters I've got to fly it and you
know briefly and he was flying it and
then the guy that he flies with he went
totally Apocalypse Now we were out in
the desert and he was just [__]
hauling ass about like it felt like 10
feet off the ground
and I'm just thinking like
that's what's like
have you ever flown yourself to a gig
no because it's it's just too much
pretension pretension yeah and what land
on top of an improv no I I
good night everybody
you know that reminds me of like one of
me me and uh uh Patrice were getting
sick of the road We Were Somehow riffing
one night and we came up with the fact
like what if you were a superhero
and you still were a stand-up comedian
you didn't stop crime or anything you
were stand-up comedians the greatest
things you could fly yourself home every
night you'd just be like
anybody
he probably said that I was saying how I
want to have like enough money to have a
helicopter and as I'm doing my closing
bit like like a hook comes down and I
just put one foot on I just wave and
they take me up and I'm in the
helicopter and then they just Cruise me
over to the airport and I'm [__] out
of there and that's what we started
riffing on and then some I forget I was
probably no one it was probably him
because that's really funny idea was
that he was basically be a superhero
and then instead of a sport coat you
have a cape you guys have been great and
he would just fly him every night even
if you're doing a week at a funny bone
you could just fly yourself home to your
lair or whatever the [__] you call it
all right everybody it's stamps.com
you know 2023 is already well underway
so don't wait any longer to level up
your small business and set your year up
for Success get ahead of the competition
by using stamps.com to mail and ship
stamps.com lets you print your own
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes so you can get back to running
your business sooner uh with rates you
literally can't find anywhere else like
up to 84 84 percent
I said 80 poor I'm not saying you're
poor 84 off USPS and UPS get access to
the United States Postal Service and UPS
shipping Services you need to run your
business right from your computer
anytime day or night no lines no
traffics no waiting you stamps.com to
print postage whenever you do business
all you need is a computer and a printer
they'll even send you a free scale so
you'll have everything you need to get
started
if you need a package pickup you can
easily schedule it through stamps.com
dashboard set your business up for
Success when you get started with
stamps.com sign up with the promo code
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
they're not trying to lock you in just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and enter
the code Burr b-u-r-r rocket money
try it for free for 30 days
um is enough time to try and completely
forget about a subscription or service
before you know it you're paying for a
subscription you don't use every single
month with rocket money you can change
that with a few quick Taps do you know
how much your subscriptions cost most
Americans think they spend around 80
bucks a month on subscriptions when the
actual total is closer to two hundred
dollars
if you don't know exactly how much
you're spending every month right if
you're laying on the ground drinking
wine you're just out of control with
your subscriptions you need rocket money
the average person has around 12 paid
subscriptions think about that
parentheses pause for two seconds can
you wrap your head around that everybody
in two seconds if you think you're only
subscribed to a handful of services you
might want to double check with rocket
money you can quickly identify and
cancel all of your unwanted
subscriptions this siphon in money out
of your wallet there or maybe you call
it a billfold uh rocket money money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about like streaming
services you bought to watch you know
porno sites or or I don't know maybe you
were into the dark web [__] you were
trying to buy a [__] grenade you know
you forget you got to kick them the big
every month rocket money will quickly
easily and easily identify your scripts
subscriptions for you
can you tell him in a rush I always read
that enough but now I'm gonna [__]
rush you so you can't stop paying for
the ones you don't want
oh so you can
that's a big difference you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want
simply find the subscriptions you don't
want and press cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you no more long hold
times with customers you know they're
not going to pick up the phone they're
going to break your balls these guys
will make it easy for you over 3 million
people have used rocket money saving an
average of 720 bucks a year all right
just think of the dumb [__] that you
could go out and buy with that 720 bucks
stop throwing away your money and cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com that's rocketmoney.com
rocketmoney.com
I saw some clips of you when you had
pneumonia where you had the same cough
so I'm sure you oh yeah that that was
not uh I I had such a cough like uh
doing like your hair hurts yeah you know
that that's what it felt like I don't
have any hair on my head I'm going what
is this and then the doctor told me I
said oh when you cough that much
you know I don't know I don't know what
you said I was just like yeah I think I
I had two hernias and they said it's
likely from coughing from 40 Years of
smoking coughing at night and blew out
my guts
that's not possible
a smoker's cough can act like you picked
up a piano afterwards
yeah it it can get pretty violent
like if you get sick and you're a smoker
the [__] cough lingers for a month or
two all right has your
your coughing fits your smoker's cough
has it ever set off a car alarm or a
house alarm so that's what I'm just
picturing
you coughing like as loud as De Niro was
laughing in Cape Fear when he was behind
those people I've never seen that one
that's another one I've never seen
yeah that's not old movies I [__]
hate like I would never watch Gone With
the Wind or anything like that no most
of the ones that they recommend yeah uh
at Maltese Falcon is great all right and
what's his face uh what is it Peter uh
Peter Laurie dude if you watch him
trying to steal this scene from Humphrey
Bogart the [__] the business he's doing
he has this cane and he's tapping it on
the floor he's spinning it he's looking
at it and [__] and and Bogart is just
sitting there being him he doesn't he
you know he doesn't quite pull his Focus
but like it's you know I remember just
like watching that and it just cracked
me up going like man that [__] has been
going on forever like actors trying to
do things stage each other yeah like
they do [__] it's funny because
comedians we have like this really bad
reputation for being like you know
they're out for themselves and it's
really cut throat and all of that type
of [__]
and we'll really just kind of hang out
breaking each other's balls I mean it's
definitely a couple of lunatics I'm not
saying all actors are like this but that
is like a thing like there's a famous
one that I saw I mean it's a story I
can't confirm it but in the uh The
Magnificent Seven
when Steve McQueen and Yul Brenner are
riding that that little wagon with the
body in the back up the street and
there's all of these [__] guys they
say I forget why if you went up there
they might maybe we're going to get shot
um Steve McQueen is loading a shotgun
and Yul Brent is like doing his lines or
something and he starts shaking
the little whatever you call it the
bullet thing and then listening to the
pellets or whatever and you see Yul
Brynner literally gives him a look which
um I always took it as a kid like he was
looking at him like let's do this [__]
and they were like he was [__] pissed
at him
that he was like trying to like it's
like I'm doing my lines I had somebody
one time like [__]
they're coming around and it's my
coverage and they already improved and I
played with them and everything and they
came around to my coverage and this
person is still improving doing
different [__] and it's in this stepping
on my lines and they're sentencing me to
ADR and all of this [__] then not
[__] work with me and I just wanted
to be like buddy they got you [__]
already like what are you trying to do
now and it's like it was one of those
things where it's like you've done this
[__] enough that you know what the [__]
you're doing I've had that happen on I
did a number of times uh very small part
they could cut thank God from uh Chris
Rock's movie what do you mean thank God
I got this thing here
where you are you are voted actor or the
[__] year what is it where is that
it's uh
but this was this was Chris Rock's movie
I forget what it was called it had every
comic best actor Doug Stanhope and can I
say the name yeah yeah the road dog Doug
Stanhope
double threat you do a little tap dance
here we can we can leave one movie and
made it to one festival and I won one
award and I'm quitting there you go
but the Chris Rock thing I had a top
five I love that movie yeah I was
playing a cop and then I I had a couple
lines and I I was there for like [__]
14 hours and they just kept sorry about
this we're gonna push your seniors later
and uh then then I got in there and he
goes yeah just just riff with it like I
memorized my lines I have nothing to
riff I'm not a riffing guy
you didn't say that did you no I tried
and failed what is what I did it I look
like an [__] but no you don't you
just well you'll make the movie well I
mean that probably has nothing to do
with that and I was supposed to be
racist I think I was I had to say the
n-word and I'm like that's just very
uncomfortable for me it's not you saying
I know but you got to lead into it yeah
but then not if you're when you're
ad-libbing you go okay this might sound
like it came from me oh yeah well I
would I wouldn't add living N word I
would do the scripted N word no there's
definitely rules to this [__] exactly it
was very big
that ain't gonna be good
um so you got you gotta you know even
though you lost the roof on your house
yeah so you're an award you are an
award-winning actor exactly and that's
why I did I get this offer it's not a
big budget picture uh you probably won't
see it in theaters it's going to be in
this Film Festival this Hollywood
independent real independent film is it
going to be out here at the end of the
month yeah they don't announce please
text Friday I'll go see what our date is
excellent yeah no I would appreciate a
retweet because I I did it as a lark it
was five weeks last year in Chicago I'm
like I'm not going to [__] Chicago
I'm not an actor first of all right I'm
not gonna freeze my balls up for five
weeks in the worst place and you did it
look what happened and I did and uh yeah
then I hadn't heard a thing about it and
then then all of a sudden oh yeah you're
gonna win best actor I'm like wow [__]
there you go there you go look at that
you are an actor and I'm a movie star
because I you're a star in this movie an
award-winning movie see that thing
anybody can come in and do a scene right
and get the little hey Best Supporting
little [__] little two-shoot thing
you did there right but you you actually
you had to carry the move you put that
movie on your phone when I played the UK
party gave us uh some edibles and we
decided to travel with them when we were
flying to Glasgow so I'm also an
international drug Smuggler
award-winning movie star wait when did
did you consume every night of the UK
tour oh so you brought it with you yeah
he gave us a giant bag on one of the
first nights if you were a woman you
would have got arrested like that woman
in the WNBA but because of your
privilege people who bring drugs to
other countries are [__] idiots this
was from you know London to Glasgow
on a [__] idiot why would you do the
cookies they were cooked dude I don't
even know can I tell you something I
don't even know the laws of this country
everybody acts like they do you don't
know what the [__] laws are I don't
know I'm not going to some other country
they can paddle me in [__] public
well to be funny to a fence Hennigan
carried them so but I was a mastermind
of the you piece of [__] you know I
remember a long time ago I used to work
in a warehouse and there was this guy
always had a new car right and he was
like 10 years older than us and we used
to go out drinking and then when we
would be done drinking hey you want to
take him for a spin we'd be like yeah
he would have us basically drive drunk
home most of the way
so he could get home for free
son of a [__] do you know what's funny
about that is I didn't figure that out
to like 20 years later you know that you
just sit down thinking going wait a
minute
that guy didn't want me to drive this
Mercury Cougar because he liked me
he was worried we were going to get
pulled out he was trying to sober up and
make me drive most of the
guy yeah when you look back at stuff
like when I hate to even say cancel
culture but when you do that inventory
of your life like all the horrible [__]
you did how drunk you drove at points
that like [__] you should actually be
shamed for doing I never did that if I
got drunk I drove myself home I didn't
make somebody else [__] do it yeah
yeah that's that's somebody else who's
drunk but I'm saying just driving drunk
at all oh dude I've driven drunk
probably 1200 times yeah
they say you have to do it like 700
times to get caught and then I got
caught and then I didn't do it oh you
did for a while
I get out I didn't do it for a while and
then like you know a little while goes
by
it's like kicking heroin you're like all
right I got it done yet and then you go
[__] do smack yeah I I I I don't know
what it was it was easy because I
started comedy and and all the guys Dane
Patrice Robert Kelly none of them drank
so I was just like all right I mean I
just kind of do what people you know I
don't have original thoughts I just do
what everybody around me does and then I
moved to New York and it was like you
couldn't drink and drive because I
couldn't afford a [__] car so and I
wasn't really drinking that much it was
when I came to La the first time in the
90s that all of a sudden you had to
[__] drive everywhere and it was like
you'd have a couple of beers
you know but I I never drove like
hammered I remember I might I might have
I I was I lived out of my car for three
years and just a lot of cars all piece
of [__] cars and wanted to break down
and I'd buy another 400 car whatever it
got to a point where I had a Colorado
license because my license was expiring
so I just got oh I'm in Colorado you get
it the same day so I got it there I had
New Mexico plates and Oregon insurance
or something that sport coat on and then
you get pulled over
isn't my mullet ears and I got pulled
over in Minneapolis and uh I was I was
pretty shit-faced and I gave him all my
stuff and he's like why do you have why
does none of this match I go because I'm
a road comic and you could just see him
calculating the amount of paperwork he'd
have to do for all this and he's just
just get home safe oh wow
dude I saw one recently on Instagram
where the guy tried to [__] send this
guy home just get home safe
right the people they animate these cops
pulling over people and he goes all
right just get home because he admitted
you know yeah I had a couple drinks
whatever he goes all right do me a favor
he goes just drive up there make that
right park your car and walk home
because I'm gonna do your solid he goes
all right
and then he goes wait a minute he goes
where's my wallet he goes I gave it back
to you he goes no you didn't you [__]
piece of [__] and he started knocking
then he got his dumbass arrested he was
out of it the [__] guy was out of it
so
um
I don't know yeah I guess I guess I
don't know I I when I I read the like
the story like the kids [__] hucking
rocks over and overpass and I you know
one of one of them goes through a
windshield and kills a lady like how
many times was I was that kind of kid I
was a [__] we put [__] on the train
tracks
all right yeah I had a kid uh live down
the street from him and we put a office
desk on the train
then he used to climb up the tower
then the guy be blowing the [__] horn
they would be going like that you know
by the time it was just one of those
things there was just no cameras and
[__] he put like a sofa on there I mean
it was no match for the train it can
destroy like a [__]
it was just amazing what was weird was
we were on like the desk flying side of
it it was really stupid but none of us
were doing well in physics so do you
know Glenn wool
uh no Robert wool Glenn Wally said comic
he's a Canadian lives in London uh for
England New Mexico but we're yeah we're
right now we're in London and where it
said pre-airbnb but it was basically an
Airbnb that were put up in and it was I
know three or four stories up and it had
we're on the roof we have the outdoor
smoking patio there and we were against
[__] hammered and I'm sure there's
probably some coke involved I don't know
like trash over there is impossible they
don't have trash cans in the street
because evidently they blew them up back
when there was terrorism or it's so hard
oh is that what that is so I have all
this trash that's uh accumulated and
we're [__] hammered and starts
throwing our trash off the top of this
apartment building into the [__]
sidewalk like four in the morning
because we're above all the CCTV cameras
and woke up the next day go I I could
have killed someone yeah
and I don't have the excuse if I'm a
juvenile delinquent I'm in my [__]
40s
heavy trash bags full of [__] beer
bottles oh no Street
yeah
Jesus Doug yeah and you think I'm gonna
[__] worry about being you know
depression
20 years ago I got one of those
[Laughter]
we used to get hammered down at Faneuil
Hall all right and it was this fire
escape we would climb up me me and this
uh buddy of mine and we would go up
there and talk about life we called it
the roof truth and you go up there and
you'd have to say what was going on in
your life you know [__] you know some
chick broke your heart how old are you
20s right
and we used to always looked down there
was this Skylight at the top of this
staircase of a lower building and when I
think we were just up to
go towards your comments you give me if
I throw a [__] bottle right through
that thing
and uh
we didn't do it and then we just kept
every night that we and every time we go
up there and then eventually one of us
threw it I can't remember I think it was
the other guy I don't remember it did I
I don't know if it went through but I
was just thinking what if some woman was
coming up there and it came through the
glass cutter face it just
I was probably like 11 maybe 10 11 12
but my brother got his first BB gun and
our parents went out left us alone at
home with a BB gun so we lived right in
the Paxton Massachusetts right in the
Town Square so we're trying to shoot the
liquor store sign from across the street
because we're right there and and our
parents are getting close to getting
home so uh
we're on the whatever you call it the
[__] a roof of the the sun room right
I guess you'd call it uh yeah
it's not called a sun room but it's that
country's way a [__] a Florida room
you know it's attached but it's low I
feel like I'm agreeing with you anyway
the point is we're on the [__] roof
but my brother has eight pumps in it and
he just does this to shoot the last
bullet and it hit a lady's driver's side
window and it just felt like a waterfall
and she locked up her brakes and I
remember us thinking we might have
killed someone at that age just sitting
turned on the TV like one day at a time
is on and we're trembling and trying to
keep everybody act cool yeah
yeah this is what you did before the
internet everybody this is why video
games and the internet are a good thing
because I think it kind of keeps people
but then they escalate it right then
they reenact the game and they go down
to a mall and [__] shoot everybody I
don't know I don't know what they do
like our our like low-level terrorism
you know what the worst thing about
terrorists are is it doesn't [__]
work and then they always take now we
got to spend nine hours at the [__]
airport and there's no trash cans and
[__] that's what she accomplished you
made The Average Joe's life even more
[__] miserable because this is not
you can yeah but that guy does walk down
the street in London and go see no trash
cans yeah
that was me
all the pollution goes right in the
[__] gutter that was me
you smell that
because of me
I was actually rebelling against the
queen
she never heard about him
I love that you're trying to take out
the queen so you blow up trash cans like
she's anywhere near a [__] like they
never seem to get the people that
they're upset with yeah it just has to
be just a bunch of [__] regular
people
like I think people would like
terrorists a lot more if they
occasionally hit their targets
well what murder is I remember I did a
bit about it I think that I'm uh well
there's a it was one of the cop killings
where they had killed a black guy uh on
our black guy and then it was Baton
Rouge and then like that that same week
some black guy came out and killed a
couple of cops or three cops or
something I go well that would have
worked out if like you killed the actual
cop that killed the on our black guy
yeah then the whole world would go that
worked out yeah because for all you know
you just killed three cops that were
actually good guys yeah yeah if you
actually got the one that pulled the
trigger then it's a wash ah emotions
yeah motions they run High next thing
you know you're blowing [__] I think
it's more sloth it's laziness I'm just
gonna kill whoever I see first yeah I
don't have time to try to find the cop
that actually did it right yeah
are we all guilty of that
once you sit down yeah that was you know
what it was like a mass murderer that
went out and just killed people that
most people would agree deserve being
murdered and then they'd build a statue
of you well that kid in Wisconsin you
know one of the people he killed was a
child molester oh yeah that was one of
the few yeah that red house kid that was
one of the few we were like was that
publicized yeah well I mean not
initially
not initially initially it was like you
know like all of that [__] happens like
people want to get rid of guns leave
that detail out like everybody's
spinning it that was what was so funny
about that one guy's show where he would
be like there's a no Spin Zone but don't
we all do that yes we all do it's just
like it is impossible if you want to go
somewhere you say come on it's only like
20 minutes away and if you don't you go
[__] it's like half an hour I don't
wanna yeah you think I didn't just hand
select the Dirtbag stories I wanted to
tell you from my past
I'm not going to tell you all my drunken
[__] escapades of [__] driving
like an [__] are you drinking Lily no
no I quit in uh 20 at the end of 2018. I
got kids dude it's just something about
being drunk
and you know how many facts I got okay I
had to stop listening to your podcast
years ago because you did not get any
facts from my podcast just little things
like you yeah you supposedly if you quit
drinking for like 40 days your liver
regenerates
just little things like that that I take
as medical fact oh yeah yeah no no I've
never done the full I don't even know
but I don't know if that's but you said
it cleanses it I had to stop I because I
said it but I'm not sitting there with
like a medical degree I know that's what
I'm saying I'm aware of that but if if
it's knowledge that you want to hear
it's factual
there you go
yeah well what what my my disclaimer on
my podcast is when I read out loud and
then it's just like if you're listening
to anything that I say after you listen
to me [__] read out loud that's
definitely I always I'll also use that
when I try to free form uh some ads from
my podcast my [__] producer goes
mental like no just read what's on the
paper because we've gotten fired from
some some companies but for really funny
[__] yes and I'm like I always use you
like [__] Bill Burr I said it was
partially famous for [__] up the what
was what's cherished and they wanted me
to take that down and I just didn't I
was like I didn't say no I just didn't
respond to them and then they sold way
more and then all then halfway through
the week they spun it around
and then then I did another read and I
pissed him off again right uh
uh no they they kept coming back they
did yeah that was uh the one and done
one was uh Nature's box I read it as
Nature Box they said oh you're going
down on mother nature and that was
healthy snacks I don't need this just go
eat an apple oh it went right out the
door
[Applause]
I just remember that well who needs this
[__] oh this is all sugar oh then you're
gonna get hungry again
yeah yeah every once in a while you
gotta burn a sponsor that's what that's
what we had one was the the one of the
sheets
uh Brooklyn and Brooklyn and sheets and
they say it's started by this couple
whatever their name is is in the ad copy
so we every time we'd make up these
Fantastical situations about how like
their friends of ours yeah Roy and
Janiece or whatever their [__] name
is you know what one night
they're getting a domestic and uh he hit
her over the head with a statue
thought he killed her now he's Chad my
buddy Chad is helping him move the body
and then uh all of a sudden starts
kicking there they dug a hole they're
about to put her in she was just knocked
out and you know what the Brooklyn and
sheets the blood came right out of them
but it was so creative but here's the
thing though fired people would buy it
then and they're also like they would
look forward to the ads they wouldn't
fast forward through them and they
obviously know that that never happened
yeah but it's not it's not those two
people that heard it it's the [__] ad
company I [__] all over uh an audible
read got fired just saying that this
this read is embarrassing to this
product because yo audiobooks kept me
alive on the road and I'm not reading
this and I gave my own beautiful reason
for why you should use Audible and uh
but no it's because ad copy because they
were they wrote they wrote it
anyway because they have [__] three
books on it so they realize they're
paying me for three books on there yeah
now do you have to sit down and read the
whole [__] thing yeah how long does
that take forever because I read like
you
oh I know if I have a race
the first two I had my buddy Chad my uh
uh from my podcast I'd do a chapter and
then he'd do a chapter and then I'd do a
chapter but the first two was fun
because uh I would I'd stop it at points
and then have people from those Stories
podcast style go okay hang on a minute
you that's not the way I remember it so
we do well that's cool yeah it was so as
part audible book part podcast so when
you read it if you if you [__] up a word
do you got to go back to the beginning
of the sentence or the paragraph no you
have a they'll have a producer there or
the one I did during covid was on you
know zoom and they'll stop and go okay
yeah you [__] that up and do that
again do that again which was a lot how
long were the sessions uh probably six
hours a day three days can you get Keith
Richards book on Audible that's 700
pages I just can't and picture him I
would imagine he had someone else read
it
I did a
why didn't you do that don't you have an
opener running the light have you heard
about Sam Talent running the light it's
the best best one of the best books I've
ever read no and it's about it's a
fiction but it's about a road stand-up
comic
kind of like I play in this movie this
movie that by the way the road Doug
false I play a 55 year old alcoholic
chain smoking uh
waning in his career stand-up comics
still on the road dying of liver failure
so and that's basically what that book
is about he was so angry when I go I'm
doing a movie that's pretty much your
book
oh he was mad that they they did well
yeah he wanted to well he wanted to get
his book optioned and then but this yeah
he can still do his book yeah uh what
the [__] was I talking about
we would audio and Keith Richards so he
outsourced it why don't you oh so so
running the light Sam talent's book he
had a different comedian read each
chapter and I remember doing my chapter
and he was there and uh
[__] what was the word I
uh
it was Gallop it's something being in a
Gallop away and I I read it as Gallop
you know all right I think I'm too tired
we're gonna stop today yeah got a lot of
good stuff did you just say Gallop I
just
I do that I've been I can't read
anything I kept calling uh
I you know what's funny that that singer
Adele yeah like I knew her name was
Adele and when I would go to read it I
would say Adelaide
I think it's one of those things right
after it comes out of your mouth you
feel your cheeks getting red like oh God
did everybody hear that
do they all know how stupid I am now you
can see that in people's faces I think
but but I like doing that because I feel
that that inspires people they're like
this guy just said Adelaide
and he's doing all of these gigs [__] I
got to get into that business that
sounds like it sounds like it's easy you
know can we get back to talking about
cars you talked about buying this 400
cars I remember a long time ago
when you did The Man Show
you had a uh you had I want to say it
was a Dodge Aspen Woody it was uh like
it was like a Dodge Aspen I don't know
if it was a Dodge Aspen it was it was
one of those Chrysler K cars when Lee
Iacocca came back to uh to to kick that
was an unvertible I bought off of eBay I
was really good at the man show of just
sitting there all day when I should be
writing and just buying [__] on eBay
because now I had some money
it was this like lime green white racing
stripes
and I thought it was a convertible but
they I I didn't look that never showed
it with the top up it had the the canvas
around where you would you know
have a but there was no roof they just
cut the roof off yeah and it was such a
piece of [__] we had to drive up to
Fresno and then drive it back to the lot
and we just it was such garbage wait but
I had wood on the side right I don't
think it had wood oh it didn't have wood
no it didn't I remember that carpet I
had an audition or whatever lot you guys
shot on I walked by and I was laughing
because I remember you said you used to
park it next to Road I parked yeah I had
a signed parking next to he had some
[__] hundred and twenty thousand
dollar Porsche and I parked that next to
him and I had the props Department print
up a bumper sticker that said I'm with
Brogan with an arrow towards this car
yeah
Keith Brogan always had cool cars when I
first came out to LA in like 95 a 96
he gave me a ride
from uh the Laugh Factory over to the
comic store and he was already like a
like the legend like I
like I looked up to that guy like oh my
God I can't believe Joe Rogan's giving
me a [__] ride you know and he had
something I want to say it was Japanese
but it was just some sick fast with a
big [__] spoiler in the back I think
I don't remember I'm not good with 90s
cars but he had
you know at that point I think he was on
news radio all right so he had news
radio no he had a barracuda I think
I remember that like from trick my ride
or yeah I don't know no I don't think it
was that no no no no I think he because
those guys those guys on Pimp My Ride
all right what was hilarious was they
would redo the whole car but not the
power train or nothing so you still have
the shitty engine and transmission yeah
it's kind of like Bar Rescue yeah with
like a fish tank in the [__]
hatchback like all right no no I know
what the [__] I'm supposed to do with
that or a flat screen I remember one
time they put a flat screen like
underneath the car and the I don't know
why people like oh that's [__] dope
like he landed back and smoke a joint
he's like that is the dumbest [__]
they did something like that I remember
that looks like back one remember when
they would have like the aquarium
lighting underneath the car and that was
considered um
like a cool thing to have you still have
that old beater pickup truck
I do I resent that it's an old beater
it's a [__] great truck 68 Ford F-100
what are we talking about yeah what runs
like it's like a kitten I bought a uh
which was supposed to have 4 000
original models beater pickup trucks
yeah it's all beater pickup truck that's
what you loved about it
wait which one you talk I've had a
couple of them the black one I don't
know is one that you had remember the
end of the world 2012 end of the Mayan
calendar oh me and Rogan and Joey Coco
Diaz okay yes you were driving it then
so it was whatever you had in 2000 no no
I still haven't yeah it's fantastic yeah
I bought a uh a Pacer that was off of
eBay I every time I bought a car off
eBay piece of [__]
but it was gorgeous like a gorgeous
looking because it wasn't I orangish
uh you know what's funny about that
there's a big misconception about the
Pacer that that car came out in the 70s
and no one questioned it and everybody
liked it I remember being in a car the
first time we saw me my mother we were
bursting out laughing going oh that is
the ugly it's ridiculous it was
ridiculous like the gremlin but whenever
they do like a That 70s Show or that
type of [__] they have everybody back
there in a Pacer and no yes acting like
people did this [__] and everybody had a
[__] lava lamp and callers out there
here it's like [__] Chevy Vega my
mother had a Chevy Vega wagon and that's
what I like that lemon law came out and
that was one of the reasons oh it was
yeah I remember guys in my neighborhood
used to buy like those [__] cars they
would somehow pull the engine and jam
like a 350 in there I mean there wasn't
even enough room
under the hood and they would somehow
I'm gonna have this kid up when you look
up those kind of cars on eBay half the
ones you find are exactly that they're
souped up you know [__] drag racing
[__] that's a fascinating thing
though that I learned about those
because you think with my ignorance I
thought if you just put a uh a faster
engine in there the car's automatically
faster and that type of which it is but
you're also adding weight so that's like
the whole like Dynamic of a race car
where it's like the more horsepower the
more weight that's why if you ever like
looked at it actually a real race car no
everything is gone right down to like
the accelerator pedal they take that it
just looks like a coat hanger hook it's
whatever that floor thinks take that out
just everything it actually looks like a
piece of [__] I was uh I stood next to
one um I went to the F1 race in Montreal
just to dump weight just to dump weight
because you all you want you just
basically want a guy in his seat and an
engine as light as possible lowest to
the [__] ground I saw one of those F1
cars like up close uh one of those Red
Bull ones the ones that Daniel Ricardo
we were in his uh area with a garage and
I was like man this thing looks like a
piece of [__] like I could put my
[__] foot through it and then the
race starts and they were just like
people just like a blur we had such
great seats man it was like right and
then the first turn so this is for what
this was for F1 yeah this is back when
uh which one the one in Montreal all
right
um I watched that first season because
it was quarantine where you watched
every [__] thing on Netflix but that
F1 series is still going but I I would
recommend uh MotoGP which is the the
motorcycle racing which I missed this
whole season I was so [__] busy this
year but like
um when I started watching it it was
Mark Marquez and uh
Andres davicioso and it was a Honda
versus a
Ducati and dude they would have these
[__] epic ends to races where in the
last two three laps they'd pass each
other like 10 times and I would be up
off my couch screaming watching this
[__] and the problem with uh F1 I found
was the cars were so [__] wide
and and
Mercedes and
um Lewis Hamilton were just so good it
was just sort of a race to the first
turn and if if Lewis Hamilton was in
first place and he was in that clean air
that was it you just watched you
basically were just watching I'd be
annoyed because the the coverage the
coverage
no super safe super safe like no one's
knock on wood has died in MotoGP uh
since like 2013
um was sort of a freak accident when
this kid got run over but um
there was one though one [__] race
man it was this long straight away and
then it had this right turn and these
two guys on the straightaway got into it
went on to the grass and they [__]
wiped out in this [__] bike was
cartwheeling going like 200 miles an
hour and these guys were turning like
this and it came flying through like uh
who was a Valentino Rossi the doctor
right he was turning like this and you
just see a [__] motorcycle just go
like it was like a trick shot wow and
they had to stop the race and he pulled
over you can't imagine how much he must
be shaking like dude like I almost just
[__] died they're like all right get
back out there and ride 200 miles an
hour 20 miles an hour on the street if
you're already doing that
like if you're already going a hundred
and [__] 80 miles an hour around
those Corners how much more are you
going to be phased by a motorcycle
almost hitting you
um every second of that you should be
shaking and [__] in your pants
yeah but I think that like with anything
that becomes like a complacency to it
all right and then we're all because
there's still [__] like as a comedian
that like can happen like I mean it does
once you start selling tickets a lot of
the days you drink at you yeah like do
you remember like back when like you
know before you became a name yeah you'd
go in and you would say some [__] and
there's this there's one thing pissing
people off and then there's another
thing of like is that guy gonna come on
the stage it becomes like a different
thing and I feel like with motorcycle
racing it's like yeah this is what we do
and yada yada yada and we got this
inflatable when I fall off the [__]
airbag comes out but we don't have
anything for that you know I would just
immediately go okay that's never
happened in my career what is the odds
that that's gonna happen again just yeah
I'm fine just it's not it's not gonna
happen to me I'll be like you gotta like
block it out but at the end of the day
this they still are human and don't want
to die despite I don't know what they're
doing why this made me think of that but
do you think if that guy from the bills
with the heart attack do you think if
that happened in the Super Bowl they
would have canceled the game
no [__] way not at all no way no
absolutely not
I don't think they would have canceled a
playoff game
I think they would have get them in the
ambulance before they tried the CPR like
uh I've heard this that you can't die at
Foxwoods uh this is my my brother's
wife's father ex-wife he's he would go
to Foxwoods all the time and had a heart
attack in a slot machine and died but
they don't they they make sure you get
off the property before they you're
declared dead you're not allowed to die
at Foxwoods I think the same thing would
happen if that guy had a heart attack in
the Super Bowl just out of curiosity
your clientele or degenerate gamblers
like that's that's not gonna he didn't
die from gambling
[Laughter]
about like I could see if there was a
okay I got one for you if you look up
shark attacks
they always say in a rare shark attack
they always say rare here's something
you don't [__] see every day well
yeah because we're on land and they're
in the water right but if they always
have like that word is attached to shark
attacks like ornate is attached to a
theater or degenerate is attached to
degenerate Gambler ornate theater rare
shark attack quaint Village yeah and
it's exactly and I just feel like that
there is a there's a little Paola going
on in these vacation spots
dude people get bit all the [__] time
if you talk to people that go to Jamaica
and [__] the Caribbean and all that
like if they go enough times they were
there when somebody got nipped in the
you know they go up and they do a little
test bite to see if you're [__]
edible or whatever it happens way more
and then when somebody finally [__]
dies
you know and they got the yellow raft
you know and that chick's looking for a
kid like in Jaws then they gotta go okay
somebody died we have to report on this
and then they go in a rare shark attack
the fact that the [__] thing comes up
I think in his nip nibbles you I'm just
making I'm just going like this once
again I'm just saying [__] here I think
if this probably like the same way you
can say it's organic you know if you
don't feed the cow another cow within a
year of [__] milk in its titties so
however they get around it yeah I feel
like with shark attacks if it's going up
just to see if you were edible and after
it's removed half of your calf realize
you aren't edible it's not an attack he
was just curious so but then if somebody
[__] dies or loses an arm
somebody loses an arm you got to make a
movie out of it that's how that works
oh God and he kept fixing shoes what was
that girl he's a one-armed cobbler
cobbler
yeah
about her I have no idea what it was due
the fact that she still would go out
there I mean you want to talk about like
I mean I can't even like the [__]
level of fear the fact that there's this
[__] thing
that could come at you and finish you
off maybe it was Hollywood I mean the
thing would be coming back to finish you
off but like my thing about the ocean is
all the [__] is I'm got my head up
here and it's all underneath there like
when I walk in the jungle all right I
don't walk in the jungle but if I was to
walk why did I just say that if I was to
go into the job
oh
like at least the [__] things it's
like I am on the same plane they are
it's hidden in a bush or whatever
there's just something about something
coming basically from another Eminem
another world from another world and
then dragging you into an atmosphere
where I can't even [__] breathe and
then getting eaten alive I mean it is
like literally you've left Earth okay
you're not on land anymore I if I if I
just like hey I'm still on planet Earth
I go anything yeah they talk about all
the time of those Jacques Cousteau
stories that is the whole other world
that has not been [__] explored you
get Dragged In it's like what's his face
is movie us when you step through the
[__] mirror right and that [__]
chick comes out and kills you and takes
over your life the same thing that that
is what goes on in the ocean I do not
[__] with the ocean on any level people
go to the beach not even late so the
balls that this woman had the ovaries on
this chick to [__] go back out there
on that stupid see that's it that's the
order plate to say guts is being a a
kind Optimist
other people might say [__] idiot to
go back out there after having your arm
eaten
I'm just saying you you put a positive
spin on it she's a gutsy lady no I think
it's [__] insane to do it but I would
say this dude I mean you know look look
at how much dumb [__] have we done in
our lives I'm [__] terrified of a
fist fight but people do it for for fun
for a living yeah they don't even get
paid for it people like to go out and
punch people in the face I asked a
professional boxer one time ago what are
you thinking when you're going down to
the ring and he was like he was an Irish
guy he's like what the [__] am I doing
why do I do this
foreign
Bell Rings they just all right I'm
[__] doing this again and just like
muscle memory takes so I had a special
call that why do I do this that would I
would that I would always be thinking
that when I would be [__] like you
know we don't have a microphone is that
gonna be a problem and you're like going
out to do is show it like a [__]
College cafeteria and I remember as they
were like going to bring back that would
always be thinking why do I do this like
why can't I just get what what is wrong
with me that I need to go up here and
make all of these [__] people like me
like why can't I just just have a
[__] job
and just go to work and be hey Helen you
know and just [__] sit down yeah but
it'd be all right with that and have a
cup of coffee in the paper be okay with
that for a [__]
six hour shift of an eight-hour shift
you'd be gone
like I love Comics who say you know if
this ever becomes like work for me I'm
gonna quit and do what get a job which
is exactly like work do you
that's a good point I'm sure you're
talking a lot of people out of quitting
they would talk somebody out of quitting
that should have quit and then years
later they do quit you know but I always
I had another eight years to that
[__] Bronco right it's the new ones
where every and we all do it in an
interview what advice would you have for
up and coming aspiring Comedians and
then you say get as much stay as time as
you can and get up every possible chance
you can get to get on stage right and
you go well most of these people are
gonna suck and you're telling people 99
of who are gonna suck to clog up as much
stage time as possible don't take no for
an answer that kid's just gonna be
pounding the [__] rotary dial I'm
sorry I'm calling a club owner sorry
like this when I was I was in the jungle
it ago
we're basically losing our minds that's
why we're all dressed up this is the
final podcast that I'm going to have
here
um anyway uh dude it's so great to see
you man thanks I will I'll shoot you a
tweet when we have uh don't wrap it up
this fast I want to say your dates again
this [__] guy if you live in
Australia I'm telling you you got to see
this guy this guy's one of the greatest
comedians of all time and there's so
many people out there that pretend that
they don't give a [__] this guy in the
best way ever truly does not give a [__]
and real you I mean what a pleasure to
just listen to somebody saying what he
thinks I give up I give a lot of [__]
in the morning
like I'm all [__]
should I start drinking and I don't give
a [__] that's why I didn't like that
that helicopter ride was [__] boring
why because I got drunk and then I'm not
afraid of anything and I don't give a
[__]
do you think maybe there was a part of
you that you were so scared that you had
to go there mentally you're [__]
boring like when somebody sees a horror
movie like dude didn't [__] excuse me
you know that there's a roller coaster
between LA and Vegas at that one place I
know right across the border and it's
terrifying now one time we'd stop there
just to wake up like you get you get
soggy after three and a half hours
driving hey let's stop and take that
roller coaster get some [__] you know
adrenaline and uh then continue to Vegas
my wife at the time and I stopped there
and decided to stay at that hotel so we
do the roller coaster first and woohoo
right and then I went down and I started
drinking and playing Let It Ride for
hours losing it's the worst game ever
and I'm just free coffee that was a
funny name and then then I let it ride
like people have endless amounts of
money yeah let it ride it should be let
that ride so then when my ATM shut me
off I went [__] it I'm gonna do the
roller coaster again and I couldn't have
been more bored I sat on that roller
coaster
hammered angry didn't care at all it was
the least thrilling thing so what I'm
saying I can take you on an amazing
helicopter right now I will look forward
to that oh you'd go up yeah well next
time you're out here call me up I'll
take you I'll show you in La you've
never seen you know what last time I
spent a million years last time I did
your podcast we said we were going to go
up to some fan you had from way up in
there the Arctic Circle in Canada and we
go yeah we should go up there together
and do a show yeah you know that guy's
still waiting for us to show up no I
wanted to do that it was in uh I've had
a couple people up it's not Yellow Knife
yeah it's yellows in it yeah Yellow
knife and then there was another place I
keep threatening to go there all right
well like now you called me out on it I
got to go up there
It's gotta be at least three planes
Tucson's got a new airline that just
flies to weird places in Canada and I
guess this I talked to a lady that was
getting off of it layer Airlines and
they they have non-stops from Tucson to
Fort McMurray which is eight hours north
of Calgary and uh from 125 bucks she
said each way and I'm like I think I
might she goes at last through March I
go I'm off when I get back from
Australia I might fly up north of
Calgary that's not so that's past
Edmonton yeah yeah eight hours North
Jesus Christ yeah that would be fun to
do I wouldn't even I wouldn't even
charge for it I just go hey if anyone
can set up because I wouldn't want to
have to go through the [__] of
getting a work visa hey if anyone's got
a stage and some empty chairs I remember
this because I've done all basically all
the prop the provinces down south where
all the people are yeah well the the the
the
colonists or whatever they call them I
want to go with the people were who used
to live down there who got sent up there
I want to do that one yeah oil rigs or
whatever the [__] they do you know I
never went back I went one time you you
hooked me up at chill coot Charlie's oh
yeah is that Anchorage of Juno you were
so angry no that's Anchorage it's still
there in fact they have a Comedy
Festival coming up the [__] uh the
comedy condo yeah the band house was the
the filthiest like of all the ledge was
literally
like like somebody took a [__] saw
and went down the middle of it it was
like itchy like cigarette burns on
everything like the TV had like I
[__] stayed there and I remember uh
right wouldn't Ralphie make a few months
later rest his soul came up to me and he
was like yeah I just did choku challenge
I go dude how about that [__] comedy
and he goes I didn't stay there no
because I don't want to be like it
looked like it did no they for it's a
liability reasons it was so they were
afraid he'd go through the floor it was
that shitty he told me he said [__] you
I'm not staying there no no that was
absolutely oh Ralphie you [__]
his lies still exist
but but it's big his fictionalizations
live on yes
you know how many porn stars blew him at
the comedy store after everybody left
oh let's not do stories let's not do
this
part of his charm it was part of his
charm
I have a funny story about that I'm not
gonna do it here I respect for a guy
who's not here to defend himself all
right that is the podcast everybody
thank you so much for listening the
great Doug Stanhope the road dog movie
The Road dog movie Road dog movie the
best actor in the road dog movies called
the road dog movie right yes or the road
dog the road dog well it's called the
road dog the road dog the site is the
road dog movie oh the road dog movie
check that out he's the best actor and
uh that's it Doug thank you so much for
coming out great to see you again all
right shook hands like we just made a
deal all right thank you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday February 10 2015. how's it going
how are you
um I'm back in the USA
I just landed at JFK a couple of hours
ago and I've been trying to get this
[__] thing done my my Olympus LS
10.
that I bought like six seven [__]
years ago it finally died I think it
finally died after a trip around the
world the old girl couldn't take it you
know she went quietly quietly in the
night
um anyways I'm psyched to be back I had
a great time and just the Whirlwind tour
around the world
I don't even know where the [__] I am
right now and I don't even know what
time it is
um yeah I do it's 5 53 p.m East Coast
time
according to my um
my little [__] little little iPad
thing here
uh ah [__] I don't know what to tell you
guys what the [__] do you want from me
you know all you [__] out there who who
gave me [__] because the podcast is so
late this week
all right you didn't have the [__]
decency
did you to go onto my website and maybe
have a little bit of empathy you'd be
like oh oh that's why
that's why it's late he's flying back
from Mumbai India
[__] three hours to Dubai another
[__] 13 hours on the goddamn plane
and some douche missed their connection
when we were in Dubai and their plane
was on their plane that bag was on the
plane
so they don't let the [__] on the plane
yet they spend 15 minutes trying to find
or 20 minutes trying to find the [__]
bag and they take it off the plane it's
like at that point why don't you let's
just let the [__] on the plane
so we can all get out of here right
I mean that's what I was doing you know
when I used to run an airline that's how
I did it so I don't know what's going on
with United Arab Emirates
Emirates whatever the [__] the airline
is that I flew uh anyways
first of all before I get going thank
you to everybody who came out to my
shows in India
China Singapore whatever the [__] I was
this week uh it was my first trip to
[__] Asia
and I had a a great time I did not get
caned in Singapore
um I didn't have any secret police
in China
and no religious crazy people got me
when I was in India
you know
so I I survived it
Singapore was Great China was great I
don't [__] know what to tell you
let's just talk about India
all right first and foremost the second
you get to India this is what you're
going to see Mumbai India you are going
to see the greatest drivers in
jaywalkers
you've ever seen in your [__] life
I've never seen just complete [__]
chaos when it comes to driving like
like I saw in India and
even like the old people were good at
jaywalking what killed me they never
changed their gate I guess gate is that
running whatever whatever [__] speed
they were walking when they stepped out
in traffic they just stepped out and
just kept walking at the same Pace the
traffic never sped up never slowed down
nobody got hit
it was Unreal I've never been in the
back of a cab so many times going ah
watch it watch it watch it and just
nobody slows down nobody speeds up
everybody just keeps doing what they're
doing it's like it was like it's like
watching Chevy Chase and Caddyshack when
he's uh [__] putting Barefoot
that's how they [__] do it
um
definitely the most insane craziest
coolest country I've ever been to was
definitely uh at least that City man
that was um
it was something else the people were
really cool uh you know first you freak
out you know when you show up
and uh we landed there at like midnight
and um
you know we showed up to the hotel and
there's a guy with like a machine gun
and somebody checking for bombs
underneath the [__] car
you know which creeped me out at first
and there was like a metal detector
going into the [__] hotel but then I
was just like all right now that I'm in
here I got a guy with a machine gun
standing out front this is way better
than a Red Roof Inn
so I guess it's just a big I guess maybe
back in 2008 they had a terrorist attack
so ever since then in the hotel I wasn't
got attacked or whatever so now they
just have a guard there all the time but
other than that I didn't see anybody
with the gun it's a really safe City the
food was [__] tremendous and uh
I did the show the last
show of the um
of the uh of the tour sorry guys it's
gonna be a lot of [__] mental uh
brain farts here this week I'm just
trying to take in everything that I saw
um
it was awesome and I got to hang out
afterwards I went out and got dinner
with me in like 20 Indian comics and
just sat there talking comedy for a good
half hour 45 minutes before I had to go
to uh
the airport which was uh one of the
highlights of my career to be honest
with you to be able to talk to people on
the other side of the world that do what
I do you know and um
you know this these guys I'm going to
send you a link to this although maybe I
shouldn't because I know they're trying
to lay low but for those who listen to
the podcast I did over there those same
guys got in trouble because they just
did a [__] roast right
and according to them it was way Tamer
than anything in the in the U.S but uh
they haven't had I guess a lot of roasts
that might have been the first one and
they did it they roasted a couple of
Bollywood guys and everything was fine
everybody laughed everybody had a good
time and then for whatever reason either
they posted it online or somebody else
did and the second went online
you know you know what happens the
second something goes online everybody
starts going oh my God what about the
children
what about the [__] religious thing
that I believe in what will this comedy
do to that
you know what I mean like they will it's
it's a [__] roast everybody's
laughing having a good time so whatever
so they everybody freaked out and
um
it got like eight million hits and uh
they're like sort of in trouble but not
in trouble but they're in trouble like
they could spend eight years in courts
with I don't know what lawsuits or
whatever
I was reading some of the comments and
someone was just going like you know
what does this say what is this going to
do to society and blah blah blah blah
and it's like have you [__] looked
out your window over there
Jesus Christ they got like a New Delhi
they have like a major problem with
rapes
is a roast gonna make that any worse
you know what I mean Jesus Christ I mean
I mean I'm not even gonna [__] say
some of the [__] that I saw over there
I saw a stray cow
a stray cow
it's just this [__] it's awesome see
I don't want to say a half of this [__]
because I don't want to scare people
from going over there because it's one
of the coolest [__] places I ever
went to
um but yeah you'll see like a stray cow
eating garbage next to her like a
Mercedes-Benz driving by okay so you got
you got the entire [__] colors of the
rainbow there it was it was awesome man
and the uh the food was insane can't say
enough about that and um
other than that what else did I get a
chance to see I didn't get a chance to
see anything oh this was the scary thing
was I went into the country and because
we [__] with
with uh
Indian people when they come to the U.S
I guess
because we're trying to make sure that
they don't illegally emigrate immigrate
whatever to our [__] uh country
immigrant right immigrate yeah immigrate
that's how it is emigrate you leave
immigrate you come in there you go bill
yeah you worked that out yourself didn't
you
um
anyways so we [__] with them so this is
Tit for Tat thing so then they [__] with
us specifically Americans from the West
Coast so they don't [__] with anybody
from the East Coast I guess
um as far as like you come to the
country and then once you get to the
country you you need another piece of
paper stamped by the government so you
can [__] leave
you know or it's some Bronx Tale [__]
like now you can't leave until you get
this [__] thing and it's
you know it's just some big pain in the
ass thing that took like two and a half
hours for me to get but
um
I guess they've had problems with
artists on the west coast but not on the
East Coast which means to me that maybe
somebody a governor or a senator of a
state on the west coast like maybe
Schwarzenegger said something I have no
idea what but somebody said something
somebody pissed off somebody sneaks you
know old freckles has got to get up in
the [__] morning and I go down to I
don't know what the hell it was but
I had this this big like
envelope of [__] with my passport my
working Visa the [__] contract for
the show all of that stuff
I go inside the building and the
promoter's not allowed to go with me
so now I'm in there
I mean this is like one of the biggest
like touristy things that I got to do
like really experience
being an idiot and I [__] go up to
the third floor and there's this big
long line of people all from different
countries trying to get this piece of
paper so they can [__] leave
and uh the line moved quickly but then
they just got you into another room and
it was like being at the [__] DMV and
you know how that goes you're going to
show up with a stack of papers like the
goddamn phone book and when you get up
there you just see the look on their
face you're like oh [__] you what else
do I need and there's always something
else so whatever I kind of Charmed the
lady I was talking to like uh
I couldn't understand her she couldn't
really understand me and I finally was
able to convey it to her that I was a
comedian
and she kind of you know gave me this
look like really you think you're funny
and I forget what the [__] I said but I
was able to make her smile
which was good because eventually I
needed the promoter to come up there to
help me get over the last
leg of it but what's funny about Indian
people is they got this thing they do
when you ask them a question they don't
shake their head no or nod yes
they do like this bobble head thing
and I was sitting there like
this white dude in Hong Kong told me
that they're gonna do that and it
actually means yes you're going to think
that they're being [__] but it
actually means yes
so this lady kept doing and I kept going
does that mean yes I mean yes long story
short one of the comics told me later on
that it doesn't mean yes it doesn't mean
no it means that there how did he put it
there uh
politely accepting your existence or
something like that I forget what it was
somebody that I asked a question to
there
I was like so if I give him all this
stuff like I'm gonna
I'll be able to get to piece of paper
I'll be fine and then they do like that
bobble head
like that you know maybe you will maybe
won't you know maybe you'll be on that
plane back to the U.S maybe uh you'll be
in that you'll be in the garbage next to
the cow tomorrow I don't know I don't
know how I don't I don't know what to
tell you so I'm just gonna do this
[__] thing with my head
so I got a big kick out of that and um
here's the thing too like I've really
been working on my temper I stayed up
there for two hours and 45 minutes I
never lost my temper once at one point I
sat down I looked up with the lady and I
was just like I looked down at the
floors like how [__] long is this
gonna [__] it's the worst I got sort
of whispered that then I just looked
around the room and I saw this family of
four from the Philippines and they were
in front of me and I'm like all right
they're still here the guy was behind me
he's still here so everybody's waiting
the same amount of time
you know for the love of God Bill
[__] relax
um
so whatever but uh
I just oh my God I saw so much [__] over
there so quickly went down to this um
they having like this street fair thing
and they had all this you know brought
my wife down there they had all this
amazing clothing and all that type of
[__] and artwork and all that type of
stuff I it's just one of those things
you just walk around like I'm in [__]
India right now I couldn't believe it
and uh then what's funny is you go out
to go do the show and you feel like
you're in the United States
it's the exact same thing people laugh
at the same [__] it's just that when
Singapore Hong Kong and India they had
like these
you know don't talk about the government
don't talk about religion don't talk
about race
and then you go to the show and the
comic in front of you is talking about
all of that [__] and basically how it
works for you to really get in trouble
with that you would have to be basically
living in the country build up a
reputation for doing it all the time and
then eventually one of those governments
will be like all right let's send let's
send somebody down there and then they'd
go down they'd watch you and
and all you get is like a fine either
they find the promoter the venue or
possibly the performer I don't know it's
not really like
you know
harshly
um
enforced
which is actually was a pleasant
surprise
with the way everybody's taken
everything so goddamn seriously lately
like every [__] thing that you say
now is just like
I mean it's [__] ridiculous and I
really think Comics have to hold the
[__] line here
and not apologize or else
I mean I don't know where it goes from
there unless you want comedians just up
there talking about widgets
and what kills me about these so-called
outrage is it's such a small percentage
of the population
first of all you realize how many people
could just give a [__] about stand-up
comedy
like if you walk down to the amount of
people that the small percentage of
people who've actually been to a live
show
you know it doesn't even [__] appeal
to like 80 percent of the population as
far as I know
you know what I mean they're doing other
things
they may be into music or they just
watch sports but like you know what's
[__] up
like I love stand-up comedy before I
became a comedian I only went to one
show ever
and I was almost 24 by the time I
started so I could legally
could have gone to Stand-Up shows for
like six years
18 plus and then once I was 21 I could
go to anything
and I never went
I only went one time and I wanted to do
it for
a living
so
I don't know
all right and of course this stupid
thing just crapped out on me um really
having a rough go here with the
technology on this trip I apologize to
everybody uh anyways what was I saying
um
I guess I was just talking about how few
people actually even give a [__] enough
to even go to a stand-up show
um so if a comic says something it's
really not affecting that much of the
population that really like who the [__]
lives their life by what a [__]
Comedian says in a goddamn joke
so ridiculous it's just got to be uh
I don't know I'm really hoping this is
just a fad
to be taking comedians seriously but
anyways that's the end of the whole um
the whole world world tour thing um it
was really insane I went to five
countries in three weeks
I did uh 11 shows in nine different
cities five different countries I don't
know how many different time zones
and it's the first time I ever was in
Asia and um
I just it was it's just a part of the
world I never I always wanted to go you
know and I just
never you know you just don't think
you're ever going to get to do something
like that so uh thanks to everybody who
listens to this podcast watches my
specials and all that type of [__] and
uh I actually learned something people
downloading my specials illegally isn't
always a bad thing
that kills me monetarily but had they
not done that overseas then they
wouldn't have seen me so uh
I don't know I'm starting to rethink
some of that [__] although I do stand
hard
as far as I got a hard line on the
[__] I stand hard you have my dick
standing up I got a hard line when it
comes to [__] taping me in a club
when I'm trying out new [__]
um
that's that's [__] brutal because
then I go to town
and my new [__] is already old [__] and
it's just you can't write fast enough so
can all you [__] teeny boppers uh
just take that into consideration I know
it's all about you and your [__]
Facebook pages now and oh my God look at
me with my selfie and all of that [__]
it's this was [__] hilarious now is
it's like the crowd wants to be famous
back in the day the crowd was cool and
they would just sat there all right
monkey boy you want to be famous let's
see if you're good enough to be famous
now it's like half of them aren't even
paying attention to you they're
literally like
really bill is it half of them or is it
like three four people a show all right
three or four people this show are like
already on their Twitter accounts or
Facebook or whatever the [__] they use
um
talking about themselves
trying to put myself in their position
but I just can't picture myself any show
I ever went to when I was a kid
you know if I paid to go see it I would
watch it
wouldn't you you got all [__] dated
do you duck face into the phone don't
you all right let's do a little uh a
little bit of advertising here uh
Sherry's Berries everybody
so where do we go here where do we go
here let me go back to the [__]
questions here
ah okay there's got to be a better way
to do this [__] podcast something a
little more professional well how far
into this are we
15-11 what's that 26 minutes okay let's
continue talking oh by the way I bet
you're all wondering hey Bill did you
finally have a chance to watch the Super
Bowl
you know
that big football game that's played
every year that's your home team won yes
I did not only did I watch it once not
only did I watch it twice I watched it
three [__] times sorry I gotta plug
in the judge you
um I watched it three times and uh
it's just a hell of a [__] game
um
and I actually think Edelman should have
got a co-mvp because not only did he
have a big game he knocked his defensive
back out of the [__] game
you know broke the guy's goddamn wrist
on a wonderful [__] tackle
and uh we exploited whoever the [__]
they put in for the guy that broke his
wrist that I don't know his name either
because I was traveling around the
[__] world and I don't collect
football cards anymore because they
[__] up the whole way you did it you
know back in the day you could just go
out and buy a post stack of them and
eventually you'd get all of them
you know now they try to make them
deliberately rare and they have like
pieces of game-worn jerseys it's just
not what it used to be I just wish tops
would put out a set of 390 like they
used to back in the [__] day and
someone like me could ride his bicycle
down old Freckle face bill you know and
eat your awful gum that was in there
that [__] up one football card in
every pack why can't I go back to doing
that so I'd know back then I swear to
God I I could have announced a [__]
game I knew everybody's name I knew the
offensive lineman defensive lineman I
knew [__] everybody now the only way
to do that is you got to play fantasy
football with a bunch of [__]
jerk-offs
you got to go to somebody's living room
and have a [__] draft and she sit
there with adults acting like just CEOs
of a [__] League that doesn't even
exist it's one of the saddest most
pathetic [__] things anyways let's
talk about the game
um
even though it's way over uh
uh obviously the excitement wasn't there
because I already knew I knew the end
result but I was anticipating
how I would feel throughout the game I
would say that when Brady threw the pick
uh in the beginning
um
I guess with the broken wrist
I guess that that would have made me
feel like they kind of offset but uh I
always get nervous once once there's a
turnover and I'm thinking like that's
going to be the first of many definitely
when we were down by 10 I definitely
would have been like it's over we're not
coming back from this [__]
and uh
you know that ridiculous catch I would
have completely freaked out but um I'll
tell you everybody's given Pete Carroll
[__] you know they had a great stat that
I saw I'm usually not a big stack guy
but that play that Pete Carroll called
that was run a little over a hundred
times during the regular season it
resulted in like 65 touchdowns
our low 60s touchdowns like 40 incomp
incompletions and like no interceptions
something like that was like 64
no like 65 66 something like that
touchdowns and 45s a little over 100
times they tried it but there was never
an interception until that place so
it's just one of those [__] things
and God if anybody knows it's just one
of those [__] things it's a Patriots
fan with like the helmet catch
you know that [__] ridiculous past
that Eli threw after Brady to Welker
[__] the bed
um
but you know what was [__] hilarious
was seeing Tom Brady's face after that
ridiculous catch that that guy in the
Seahawks made he just he just had to
suck on his face like
like really like how many times do I
have to win the Super Bowl
before I I actually
and the defense will just [__] get a
goddamn three and out
and let me ice the [__] game how many
[__] times do I gotta drive down the
[__] field for the go-ahead touchdown
I did it in both [__] Giants games
and you guys are out there letting
people catch it between their taint and
their [__] ankle
for the love of [__] God
you know that whoever that Patriot was
that jumped up and over that's the
result of those [__] don't don't
hit a defenseless receiver because back
in the day
even though Malcolm Butler tipped that
ball up that other that safety coming
over the top he would have gone right
into that guy's jaw he wouldn't have
hurled him like oh don't step on the
receiver it wouldn't knock the ball out
so thank God and uh I loved seeing a
drunk
um Robert Kraft and I love that he
demanded an apology that [__] Jim
ersei what a bunch of horseshit did you
guys see that thing ESPN did where they
had the uh the Science Guy actually
investigated the advantages or
disadvantages of a deflated ball and
they actually found out that it was it
was actually a disadvantage
um
but there's an article that came out
that I retweeted now Grant it was from a
it was from like CBS Sports Boston
that really debunked a lot of the [__]
of course you guys won't believe it but
um
you know I don't know what I hope that
they pursue that they should pursue that
the way the Colts complained throughout
the years
keep complaining
right through the [__] draft
all I know is a [__] Bill Belichick
sat on the rules committee and changed
rules to make the game easier for his
offense I mean he would have to go on in
front of the Senate defending himself
Jim Murphy doesn't nobody gives a [__]
um so that's my message [__] Jim ersek
what are you gonna cry about this year
Jimmy
um anyways
what else
I'm trying to look at my list of [__]
here anything else that I wanted to talk
about
um oh and I lost my list well I guess
that
well there goes that
um anyways I'm in New York City for the
uh the Patrice O'Neill event
um benefit I should say the third annual
time is flying by and uh this is such a
wonderful event it's the most positive
thing I do every year and uh
we got a hell of a lineup this year as
always uh we got some new faces we got
some new blood uh this is the first year
we actually we got a couple guys on that
were uh
you know I think got to see Patrice
before they were even Comics I'm
guessing by their age Michael Che and
Hannibal Burruss so that's pretty cool
to have that sort of element like
watching people who were influenced by
patrice's comedy before they started or
at least very early on in their career
they were able to see them
um so I'm really looking forward to that
and once again it's just such a great
and all you guys who've gone out
throughout the years and have bought
tickets it's really you know
had such an A positive
effect on uh the people that Patrice
loved because you know unlike a lot of
[__] Charities where there's an
infrastructure and there's people
getting paid nobody gets paid like I
said the only money we have to spend is
the money that to rent out the venue and
then the rest of it goes to his loved
one so it's really just like direct like
you know when you want to help Wounded
Warriors and Veterans like you just wish
you could just be like give me the name
of the person and where they live and
can I just [__] write a check to this
person directly
um
of course then they would just put it in
the bank and then it would be considered
income and then they get taxed on it
right is that what it is ah these
[__] Cuts I don't know how to do it
uh but I think the way we're doing it is
about the best way you can do it by the
way did you see all that [__] on [__]
no more
that they don't really do anything other
than just raise awareness it's the
biggest [__] any I'm telling you right
now I am done with any charity that says
they're there to raise awareness [__] no
more [__] that uh Pink [__] in October
all of them it's a bunch they're the
modern day Flynn flam
snake oil salesmen they're all getting
rich off of of people dying of diseases
or getting beaten up spousal abuse all
of that they're literally going out
buying fancy cars and nice houses
because regular people feel like they're
doing something
of course and I haven't investigated any
of it I think they're all full of [__]
and uh
I'm done with it now I'm done but I'm
done with I think I'm pretty much done
with just about every one of them other
than uh
what's that one that Danny Thomas
started
that one has just straight like a five
star rating is it Saint Jude's Hospital
that one and then the thing I I talked
about a few weeks ago which I still
haven't done because I've been overseas
where you'd see if you're a match for
the uh bone marrow transplant we think
you can literally save somebody's life
like those types of Charities that are
transparent it's just a handful of them
you know but isn't that
that the truth with everything
I mean there's a lot of people that play
music but how many are really good
Charities are no different everybody all
right let's get on with um
oh is this a bad thing is it bad
to
to think someone's a bad mother
because they still wear leather pants
that's probably a bad thing right I'm
here in New York and I was sitting down
eating at yet another bad slice of pizza
in New York City you know New York City
is just like Chicago where it's known
for its pizza so there's so many [__]
places that are living off that
reputation
that like you know you have to talk to
somebody that lives in Chicago and
they'll tell you where to go and pretty
much they'll there's like five [__]
places Maybe
in each City that people recommend and
everything else is [__] so this
place across the street of course is
[__] and I'm sitting there I'm
eating my slice of pizza and they got
some sort of uh Latino Judge Judy thing
going on
and uh which is just
at a total different level where on this
show
the defendants can actually put their
hands on each other
I guess once one's a uh the prosecution
wants to defend whether I won't have the
[__] legal term it's the person
bitching and the person getting bitched
at they can actually
like one this guy he actually ran up to
this woman and ripped her shirt open and
pulled out
like I don't know if he was bitching
that her bra
was stuffed
but that's what he was suing her over
some sort of false advertising I have no
idea the sound was down and even it was
up it was in a different language
and I was the only one watching it other
than the guy making pizza so when he
ripped her shirt open I screamed out
what in this pizza place and everyone's
looking at me like what am I talking
about by the time they looked up they'd
cut away so
I don't know maybe they thought I was
some sort of redheaded Latino guy and I
could read lips or some [__] I don't
know what but anyway so this woman walks
in this lady walks in with her two kids
she's got on leather pants and high heel
shoes and just right there
I just immediately judged Her Like She's
she's too [__] self-involved
to be a good mom
then I was like Bill you do because of
what her pants and her shoes
am I wrong for saying that ladies I
would love to hear from you
and it's there the male equivalent to
that
wouldn't that be like the guy if you saw
a guy he's a dad of two and he comes in
and he's got his hair highlighted in his
[__] eyebrows shaped up you know
looking like he's trying to do the book
a roll for the Ricky Martin story
you know maybe wearing some cologne
you know but both of them still kind of
horn it up like are you still trying to
find a mate like what's going on here
uh probably everything I said you know
what somebody's probably gonna take an
excerpt for that and then put it on
there and then I'll be a little sexist
rats all the bloody morning broadcast
[__] morons
um anyways
yeah
there you go
I'm just being honest like I feel like
uh if I see a woman with kids and she's
wearing leather pants uh
I'm gonna say that uh
I don't know somebody might fall in a
swimming pool and it's going to take you
a minute to get there
[__]
ways Hong Kong h-o-n-k Honk Kong by the
way people who live in Hong Kong are
known as honkies how funny is that
well I think it's funny hang on
um
all right Hong Kong oh by the way India
there's so many [__] people there
like you lit it takes you a minute to be
able to breathe that [__] air
I definitely felt like uh
I've done a couple times living in Los
Angeles I've gone on a hike you know in
my leather pants
you know but I don't have any children
so it's okay my leather hiking shorts
and if I
am jogging a little bit
and I'm you know breathing hard or
whatever I felt a burning in my chest
on uh like really smoggy days
but uh I was not jogging when I was in
India and there was definitely this this
you know it takes a second for your body
to get used to oh it's going to be this
level you know
um
I haven't said all of that and as much
as a pain in the ass as it was to get
the [__] slip and all that I can't
wait to go back
um
all right Hong Kong bill you probably
already talked about this
but can you speak about the pollution
and the constant tickle in your throat
caused by the air over there if you
haven't already oh that's just something
experienced that in Hong Kong I didn't
feel I felt that in India I felt there
was that tickle in your throat
um
there was definitely
it was definitely hazy
but La gets hazy
um
but I would think a lot of that was yeah
there's just a zillion people over there
um
yeah I don't know I don't want to start
saying a bunch of negative [__] there's
already enough negative [__] about a lot
of places over there uh they're [__]
amazing cities to go to I highly
recommend it but yeah there's definitely
a zillion people and you see the effects
on the environment which is why it's
funny when people deny global warming
that we're having any sort of an effect
on the environment or any that type of
[__] and for years
that was just the beginning of time the
[__] Earth is heated up and cooled
down Jesus [__] Christ
um I am not a scientist but they seem to
be very alarmed at the rate
that it is heating up this time and this
time of year people always point at snow
storms and go you see it's snowing in
February
this one scientist guy was saying that
both the Summers and the winters are
going to have are going to be really
erratic and all I can say about it is I
hope that the the people who say it
isn't true are right
because if we're having effect on it and
we're not [__] with the population
other than to keep adding to it uh
oh my God I almost said the worst joke
ever forecast calls for a shitstorm oh
I'm such a Gemini
sorry sorry to anybody who ever remotely
even
or enjoyed comedy because I just ruined
it part of it you know what I mean
what I just did to comedy with that
awful joke was like during a war when a
city gets bombed
and uh you know
a really old historic building
gets blown up
that's what I just did really built I
think he just told a bad joke I think
comedy will be fine you [__] jerk off
all right foreign music Billy have you
developed a love for any music you've
heard while traveling
um
I traveled so much I didn't have a
chance to take in too too much of
anything
um I will tell you that uh
when I was in
Singapore
I think it was in Singapore
I walked into that hotel that has the
infinity pool at the top that you're
you're not allowed to go into I
discovered unless you were a guest I
just want to walk out and go see it
and they were like ah no I'm sorry I
can't do that and then the lady was like
well he's doing a show here in town and
they're like yeah well have fun at the
show you still can't look at the pool
um
when I was in the the lobby of that
hotel there was uh
it was these women playing
um
I don't know if these instruments from
Asia basically as far as I can tell you
know that one that has the strings but
you hit it with little hammers
uh they have it in every karate movie
that I've ever watched
um not during a fight scene it's usually
when the person comes the the Hero Comes
To Town
and uh the hot girl in the village that
the douchebag that the heroes was gonna
have to fight notice notices of the hero
when it comes to town
immediately hates the hero and then they
have to fight
over her vagina basically
um
you know that instrument that's played
in the background I like that one and I
like the music I like the mood that that
creates
uh by the way I'll tell you right now
Chinese girls are [__] hot man good
Lord beautiful [__] stunning
same thing with the women in Singapore
they all got some Cutie Pies you know
every goddamn country I went to
every country has Cutie Pies I'll tell
you that
tell you that right now and as far as
music I didn't [__] listen to
anything other than I heard that [__] in
the lobby
um that was it you know it's funny with
the hotel we were staying at in in in
Hong Kong
they um
they had all these beautiful [__]
women working there all these Chinese
women right and they all had names like
Susan and Ethel
Meg
and then you'd walk out and go to a
store across the street and everybody
would have like Chinese names and it's
just like Jesus Christ
what are you doing I know your name
isn't Helen
[Laughter]
not to do that joke when I was in you
know what I wanted to open with in India
I was just so [__] tired I forgot
I was I wanted to open with like you
know what
you know whatever it's nice to be here
in India
and I know I've already probably talked
to most of you on the phone
and uh by the way we everybody in
America knows your name isn't Scott you
know any do that is there anything else
I could help you with yeah what is your
name Scott
[Music]
no it isn't my name is Dakota that's
gonna be funny when they update it to
those [__] awful celebrity names
people name their kids now
what the [__] do they name him
you name a kid like carburetor or some
dumb [__] like that uh you help my wife
give birth the [__] out of here
um
well if she heard that joke I did a few
minutes ago she'd have a miscarriage uh
you helped me with my wife give birth
dear Billy boy
I am writing to you from my lovely
wife's hospital room and she gave birth
to our beautiful and thankfully not
red-headed little lady oh [__] you
uh my wife was a complete champ going
through 29 long hours of Labor
holy [__] no wonder they could [__]
longer than we can if they're [__]
built to take 29 hours of Labor do you
think you're going to beat them in a
fight about whether you can watch the
game or not
[__] it's over before it starts one
round loss
and now I have a huge respect for
mothers everywhere after seeing what an
intense process that is firsthand
anyways that's hilarious it took 29
hours of labor at what point did your
your opinion start to change our 17. you
know I gotta say you know these mothers
they got something
um
that's funny that I'm judging that lady
wearing the [__] leather pants she
probably went through 29 hours too right
at least between the two kids and the
fact that she can still fit into leather
pants
you know
I don't know maybe that's my insecurity
but I think she's still trolling for
[__] uh anyways
[Laughter]
let's take that out of context let's
just shove that somewhere put that on
the news anyways my reason for writing
is while she was in labor I tried to
play some music to help distract her
from the from the contractions after
about three songs and a few contractions
she said to me and I quote this music
isn't helping I need something else put
on Bill Burr's podcast [__]
Jesus Christ was that's probably why she
pushed it out
she wanted us [__] stop hearing my
dumb voice obviously I obliged the woman
giving birth to my child and we sat
there listening to old freckles distract
her from the Pains of Labor I am sure
the nurses were a bit confused when they
heard a Litany of shits Fox and [__]
coming from the phone but we didn't care
because it was helping thanks for all
you do and for helping distract my wife
for a while from her uterus trying to
push a little little wrecking ball
through the birth canal thanks and go
[__] yourself well there you go see that
my podcast
could be used for things that are good
right isn't that lovely
all right go on to the next one uh
co-worker
dear William
there's a woman or as I like to say a
[__] lady
at my at my workplace who I am in love
with
uh there was a project and I was
hand-picked oh [__] I just forgot you
know this is you know something that I
love about traveling is
the random [__] that you see
somebody bought me a cigar
um when I was in New Zealand thank you
by the way and they had a cutter and
matches and all that [__] not everybody
heard that and I said Thank you please
don't do that nobody else do that
because I'm really trying to cut down my
habit
um
but I appreciate the gesture so anyways
he gets me that and by the way if you're
going to pick out a [__] cigar you
gotta pinch the end will you put your
mouth and it's supposed to be spongy
supposed to go in and then when it comes
supposed to immediately come back and
then it's going to have a nice draw the
rest of the cigar it doesn't [__]
matter all right and uh because if it's
hard will you put your mouth
um it's like you ever have like a straw
and a milkshake that's too thick
and you can't even [__] enjoy it um
that's what ends up happening but having
said that that's another reason why I
don't want a [__] cigar from someone
in the crowd because if you're actually
pinching it I don't know where your
fingers have been and it just gets gross
so anyways but I'm smoking this cigar
anyways and uh
I'm in Auckland New Zealand right
had a great show
played this unbelievable theater and
they had this organ there that it was
one of the top five or six organs in the
world
um and you know you see an organ with
those giant pipes you just think they're
plain and that's the pipes that you're
seeing is is
you know within me all that music's
coming from it isn't it's actually those
pipes are uh
just for shelf for the most part and you
go in the back and we she this lady took
me in the back there was three floors
of
inner workings
to this organ and I'm telling you like
giant rooms
of things that you know opened and
contracted like a goddamn accordion and
then all these different sized pipes all
the way down to these little things you
could smoke crack out of
that all were part of that sound and I
guess these old guys would come in
every uh like month
to retune it you know I don't even know
if we need to be tuned that many times
but uh I guess they love the [__]
organ so much they used to joke it was
like their train set but um anyway so
it's just as far as like random [__]
that you see so I'm smoking this cigar
and it's like one in the morning
I mean [__] New Zealand other side of
the world all the way down near [__]
Antarctica it feels like and all of a
sudden somebody walks by I swear to God
with like a Mitchell and Ness art monk
Jersey
a Washington Redskins jersey I'm looking
like is that a [__] Redskins jersey
I'm in Auckland New Zealand and then
look in the back and it's it's art Monk
not only is it a dress a [__] great
jerk who the [__] has an art monk Jersey
great choice whoever the hell has that
that's one of my uh I hated him when he
played because I was a big time Cowboys
fan back then
before uh
ill uh Jimmy facelift came in there and
um Jerry Jerry facelift came in
Jerry Jones and Jimmy Johnson I've never
been able to keep those two straight uh
so anyways I like that's the type of
[__] I like it's just the randomness of
that I saw and there's a bunch of of
bootleg Yankee [__] because wearing like
a Yankees hat or anything New York is
just like you know it's like the [__]
chick who wears the Paris shirt that's
never been there a little Eiffel Tower
someday but they're not like Yankee fans
I actually heard a funny story of some
Mets fan I guess [__] living overseas
and couldn't stand that because none of
them because he wanted like [__] on the
Yankees as a Mets fan like I don't know
doesn't really have a leg to stand on
but uh he found out that they were just
wearing them to wear them
and uh oh the other thing too is when
you go into a country that doesn't
really speak English I've told you this
[__] and I saw this in France where like
like
the [__] that they have in English never
makes any sense or it doesn't you know
it doesn't mean what they thought it
meant like when I was in Hong Kong I was
reading their t-shirts the way they read
our tattoos you know we get the Chinese
characters where you think like this
means like Brotherhood this means
Serenity and it really just means like
uh you know take a left on [__]
Street or whatever the hell it means
um somebody
had uh
ah Christ I knew I should have written
down I can't remember
somebody actually had a football jersey
with the number 69 on it and where the
name went it's it's it said all night
[Laughter]
all night 69 there you go
this guy's wants to get some and give
some all at the same time good for him
uh anyways co-worker dear bill there's a
lady at my workplace who I am in love
with there was a project and I was
hand-picked to help
out in her Department not sure why but
there were plenty of other people who
could have done it well maybe it was
fate maybe it was Cupid maybe it was I
don't know what something bringing it
together anyways this person says
because of this we have worked together
on numerous occasions when I'm doing
something on the computer and she's
sitting beside me helping out I can't
help but notice she's looking directly
at me
Jesus buddy how many more [__] signs
do you need here sometimes she will be
one aisle over bent over a desk
talking to someone and adjusting her
tight jeans where she knows I can see it
okay this took a left turn
I ain't seeing relationship here buddy
I'm seeing uh
seeing a fun time for about six weeks
and then I'm seeing you losing your job
that's what I'm seeing now all right
let's keep reading here we work in a
large building and she is all the way on
the other side so we so we correspond by
text messaging oh that's always good
good move
good moves get it in writing write
something lewd to her uh believe me
she'll keep every one of these and when
it goes south she'll [__] show it to
your boss who probably also wants the
Banger we work in a large building wait
wait oftentimes
when I text her about work or have
questions she doesn't respond I'm
guessing if
she was into me she would reply back
immediately but sometimes I get nothing
or is she playing hard to get I really
want to make a move but there is a fear
of hostile work environment or worse I
get fired for sexual harassment if she
doesn't have the same feelings towards
me
it's killing me not knowing what to do
because all I do is think about her
thanks and go [__] yourself P.S I'm
married and have kids and so does she oh
[__] you that was a big waste of time
ah Jesus Christ all right I think that's
a podcast for this week right that's not
that's that was a pretty decent effort
wouldn't you say decent effort all the
way around uh that's a podcast I want to
thank everybody
um
who came out to my shows
as I toured
the south of Asia I still can't believe
I got to do that
you know what's [__] up I was in two
countries that had one of the wonders of
the world and I saw neither one of them
I didn't go to the great wall and I
didn't go to the Taj Mahal
uh
so
yeah what are you gonna [__] do I
tried
you know I did my thing
um anyway so I am in New York City right
now and I'm doing the Patricio Patrice
O'Neill benefit tomorrow night and uh
I don't know I'm on different time zone
I might go out to the clubs tonight who
knows who knows that's the Monday
Morning podcast go [__] yourselves
thanks for listening